she was a pretty good you left why'd you
decide to leave New York I was the most
successful person in New York City and
the wealthiest I think that's a little I
don't know if I broke that Wow no Brian
no I know Vince everybody not stomachs
out there man it's not true I was
successful I had surpassed Seinfeld
laughs again
Louie CK Lois see Cattell I surpassed
polo sighs Norman I'd surpassed all of
them yeah and I was I was also the
richest person in that make sense I made
more money than a lot of the hedge fund
guys I don't know how you made that more
than you know your negativities you it
doesn't eat meat you know I'm just you
know was it residuals from this so once
I got to the pinnacle of New York where
I literally owned New York society about
I had to get out to come here and then
take it over and I'm halfway there
halfway there you've been here for how
long
ah three months you came in like a tidal
wave oh but I becoming a lot I've been
coming out here Elena now becoming in
Enochs I just see me story yeah I just
started I would start but I started
working there probably three months ago
but I called Spotify the day after Rogan
signed and I said I would like 85
million dollars and they they were weird
about it but I said listen to me and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I also called Joe and I
said we honor you Joe I've been on the
show about three times I think I deserve
a little money here and I will have
lawyers high-tech Sebright them and I
said I'll have lawyers because I think I
was on his podcast more than anybody
less nine times yeah and Brian goes
appear at the very least you could buy
us houses in Texas yeah yeah yeah the
deal you suck yeah it's a good question
we could use a boat Joe the least you
can do by the way how many girls I've
seen a dime from the fight completely
delusional psychopaths now think Spotify
is giving the money how great is that
how many mentally ill podcasters are
calling Spotify I'm calling their agent
been like hey you any money over there
like how about Spotify just like oh my
god we [ __ ] or we didn't emails and
calls non-stop people demanding millions
at all I just wanted 85 mil I said
listen that's a fair deal just by the
way Spotify buy me for two male 1 mil
they're worth five billion now yeah just
just they underpaid our boiro can we
think about a care of the people
who you need to take care of that's all
yeah my cousin SARS I'd love to meet
this old [ __ ] identity late my mothers
are back you think your family's [ __ ]
up I wake up every day there's another
[ __ ] news story's not true
hi corona I'm trying to help these
people they're [ __ ] stupid listen I
live in Fox what kind of [ __ ] up she
did I live in someone's ass Candace
Owens does even believe I'm real let me
catch that big let me catch that [ __ ]
into Whole Foods
I'll go right up your nose will not be
able to transmit me to human my yeah
we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ] we're
gonna give you to every single person
that's what my dad wants to do what's it
put a little bit of mean and evil and
give it to a billion people
what do you think that does to my sense
of self I'm [ __ ] real deal you don't
even know how I'm gonna affect you
nobody knows I might like your body I
might not I'm going to some of these
bodies I'm like gets me the [ __ ] is
they're gonna ask me what the [ __ ] I
want to do with my life I want to put
something I'll have a lifestyle brand
baby nobody's maybe [ __ ] tik-tok
nobody wants to all up either tick-tock
with copa90 no one wants that
so just [ __ ] alone all the time have
you had a one last meal what would it be
you're gonna die you can have any one
that's in a death row show here's the
thing right I think about that every
night no I would I mean I would start
with a shellfish tower I'm talking about
chilled lobster shrimp crab and I would
have a creamy cilantro sauce I'd have
some cocktail sauce I'd have a little
office boys yeah nice spice who's a
horseradish in it yeah then I would move
on to like a New York Strip rare awesome
hash browns a little creamed spinach
some steak sauce
and then I ended with a hot fudge sundae
that's not a bad that's my meal uh
Robbie might not actually move gonna be
a big hulking dude I was an actress when
I was 6 2007 shoot a few times yeah damn
you've heard of it I didn't know
right now your son mandrill hit kids all
over the world believe in it I was on it
twice I made about 260 dollars good good
yeah characters like Elmo or cookie I
saw that big meth head who plays Big
Bird Carol whatever his name is uh uh
yeah and then I met and then I did the
Polka was snuffleupagus it's not for
love what gives yeah that's on YouTube
it's please bring the cats and Hulka
with snuffleupagus this is a very
embarrassed God Big Bird actor returns
it for nearly 50 years dude making well
I don't hate Tim Dylan will come up I
think it's polka with snuffleupagus
although maybe it where it is it's just
gotta be polka with snuffleupagus but I
just danced with ya there it's the third
one down oh no this is not it's a second
well I'm sorry this is always now he has
to wear that outfit yeah on the inside
of it
he's in sweating his ass up is this
right I wonder why I don't I think I
might kill myself
is that yeah you run the back there I
don't know but it's the put it is on
there today it's pokey like I dance the
Polka with them how much money did be
how much were they getting public job
you don't get any money you get no money
nobody gets any money they're begging
for my birthday hey hey they'll get paid
yeah they're you're here it is there I
am right there where are you the blonde
the 45 year old with the blonde hair the
night the kid who obviously shouldn't be
there oh my god volker dude yeah dude
that's that Long Island Bowl yeah it's
right so I get it you think you were
gonna be like far above yeah I was
Brendan thanks for bringing it up I did
think no I believe everything you're
doing right now and I know the
difference I've got everything you're
doing I feel there's not as Mark I know
what I'm doing I'll be your hands by the
way put your hands closer to your penis
there and there is it cool is he I'm
sure Frank you as a kid you're um yeah a
few kids thought it was cool um did you
go back to school the next day think
you're a big dick Harry um I think it
was
it was cool but it wasn't like yeah me
and this this chick god only knows what
happen to her huh that's the girl from
the others probably had a very well yeah
yeah
now they didn't have me do any speaking
roles cuz my voice was literally the
same as it was now there was nothing fun
about that nothing fun about it get a
little kid be alive no is natural blonde
dude good good you're Irish Irish am
Irish so I mean listen so then I got
Shawn you got out of the game I got 12
or 13 why because there's no real roles
if you are going through puberty and
look like you're going through puberty
yes so a lot of the young kids are
played by older people or they are but
you know how it is
so like and listen I tried for like six
years and got nothing I started when I
was six first play it was six I toured
around the country with a Broadway show
for two now my mom yeah I try you know a
little one on a bunch of auditions try
that for like grace under fire which was
like Brett Butler's sitcom I made it to
like the third callback and then they
found a kid who was like shorter than me
look better standing next to her that
kid was like one of the Sprouse brothers
she was such a nightmare on that show
yeah
oh my god which is a big Koko Willa's
know bring her as a comic she was
stand-up comic yeah got a huge show and
she became you were I'm sure you
remember so difficult I guess that she
just that was the closest I ever got was
great under fire I got the second
callback third callback I was gonna go
to screen test in LA and my mom and dad
were like oh we're gonna get where we're
gonna be rich because they think they're
gonna be rich too
he's still like oh we're gonna we're
gonna take your money Macaulay Culkin so
yeah we're gonna go and live in LA we
can ditch Long Island yeah you know we
can Chuck Lorre yeah it did she was such
an ayah Maris and then and Holly was
like I have no idea let's see the kid
look how close they might have that care
very much you know what I mean no I I
almost got it bro
the kids pretty cute you know what
Brendan didn't see the acting ability
shoot you didn't see what I could do
you're right can you tell me what I can
do you're just judging it I'm not and I
think you are but see
yeah I almost got who's on there yeah
that kids piney I was not that's not
it's not what's the name from Frasier
knows that no that dears no that is just
even that [ __ ] know this move show the
other thing is like dude this whole
thing about people partying in the
Ozarks it's like why does everyone a rat
now everyone's a rat and everybody's
like an informant because they have
nothing to do yeah I hate that it's so
straight ox dude I'm not in Oz look like
I'm not in party Cove in Ozarks that's
not I wouldn't have been there probably
before I don't care yeah I don't care I
let it follow it and all the people that
are mad at them they're like oh they're
gonna die it's like will you hate those
people I think you don't care about
people in the Ozarks you look at Florida
like my aunt Donna called me sick these
rides day people are gonna die they're
so stupid I'm like will you hate him
anyway so from New York he'll roll the
dice laughs let him have fun party Cove
in the Ozarks baby
it's fun they want to get together it's
what they want to do man yeah I would
love if they like did a camera close-up
on a dude there and they asked him a
question like hey why are you out and he
had like a brilliant scientific answer
yeah though were like something really
smart you know he's like listen if you
look at the mortality rate over a period
of time and you're like why he has a
corona corona your minds blown
he's like yeah thank you have a good day
you know is it thanks so much he makes
all the sense yeah yeah you like this
guy's [ __ ] great everyone's like yeah
let's get out there he's smart but
that's the thing I think people just
gonna have to stop ratting other
people's eyes very well on rogue instead
spitting out some fat yeah Ron goes
where are you getting that was right he
goes what are you getting this
information yeah why didn't bring the
[ __ ] divers also makes a joke and I
can't think of the site yeah I get first
of all I love it it's like it's Teddy
Bravo friend from Italy people on that
show Hillary Clinton snorting babies and
it's like okay well just nobody's asking
how about we ask for a source on that
you know
I don't know man Apple I hear [ __ ] and
I'm a man of pure mind and body and soul
I take this is all just a two-hour
flight which is fine all I said was the
gates goes into the third world and
every now and then he pricks something
and sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and I'm right about that that
doesn't mean we don't need vaccines
that's right it means that I'm right
about that him and Melinda go on a
vacation to the third world would a
needle and just sit there and go are you
sure that's how it's done I feel like
your face is exactly how it can you show
me the technique underdeveloped country
and they go and they have like a fake
carnival okay and and and then people
are brought to them people are brought
to the carnival and everyone's like
having fun everything like that and you
know that thing where they throw you
know the ballgame they throw the dart
into the balloon yeah then what happens
is well you're not looking bill takes
the dart he goes I guess that's what
happened and sometimes it works and
sometimes what's he putting in the kid
anything vaccine to see if it works and
then sometimes the kid turns into a
werewolf sometimes that's what it is is
you have her facts so baby where anyone
listen do you believe in pizza gave Tim
some of it this has been a very like
your science I have the facts bring
those words from Rogan cuz we expect
that's it I know facts matter fact
matter do you look at a guy like me go
he's got the facts that's her word first
yeah he's got to stand outside of my
shows I go this guy's got the fastest
sector that's max he's got we make a
statement that's completely not true and
this is how we always get out of it okay
my father does this all the time he'll
say something that's completely provably
untrue about something is gonna happen
in the future we go why do you think
that he goes watch why
he's done like what do you mean he goes
watch it's a way to win he wins and he's
like he'll be like that [ __ ] happen he
goes like this that business he goes
that business going out of business
there we go what do you mean they're
killing it every night he goes watch I
walked into another he's right into him
hey Allen Road it was like dude what do
you say Bill Gates gonna is gonna hit
you up man you say in this show you like
I hope he help me and Bill Gates are in
a big fight but no he's right about that
actually buy some of you but the reality
is I'm a comedian I'm here to bring
levity to a troubled world yes that's
reality also used fact and I use facts
and I know stuff because I'm a smart boy
yeah but you know cross-reference what I
see has to be a Native American woman
slash before you a Chinese yes and the
reality is I kept saying to Rogan watch
watch watch dude no one that I grew up
with his ever spoken with the fact
no one's ever science always that's
always started the show yeah like we
have everyone else at nobody and Rogan
used to say stuff and then people would
[ __ ] call dude we get death threats
over our Korona talk Jay gets him all
the time they see me Jay goes we're in
so many death threats on kronum death
threat death threats Jay who about what
about I'm not saying that's all he's
here about of it you get death threats
over that oh you met Jay yeah we're not
saying that be careful though Dallas
stealth
what are they saying just that we should
we don't be die I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]